because I was just there it was  something that I didn't I didn't even  think I could say that at 20 and 25 I  wasn't even thinking everything was just  kind of like an instinct the thing and  there like when I think back to my life  in those days like I wasn't thinking I  was just there it was just existing you  know it wasn't until late 20s that I  started like questioning some things  thinking about other options in life and  you know you get older and you know you  just start going up and growing apart  and I was separated my ex-husband and I  and then she were divorced and  that was a whole life change you know I  became pretty much somebody else because  you you shed that that shell of who that  is and this excuse me this new person  comes up of who you are now and that  continues to happen over and over and  over again it is exciting